you know it's so funny because we've
spoken but this is like our first time
officially speaking
uh in the context of a talk show yes
in fact i i'm fairly certain i have a
photo with you
backstage at the book of mormon yes um
because my co-star josh gad always knew
every celebrity that was coming to the
show
really very on top of it yeah and he
would tell us all like
guess who's here guess who's here and um
yeah and then you know sometimes
folks would make their way backstage
after the show which you did and you
were very um you were very
gracious about the show and very kind
the show was obviously one of the
all-time
funniest uh broadway experiences uh i've
ever had
uh just relentlessly funny and you guys
were all so fantastic
and i did make my way backstage i
actually made my way if you remember on
stage several times during the show
um i like to make my
i like to make my presence known so so
i'm known for when i go to a show i'm
not happy just being spotted in the
crowd i like to make my way
up and do this in front of the crowd
during a scene and i apologize you would
have fit into that show
very easily i think you could have
definitely you could have been a
missionary
i'm yeah i very much have that uptight
missionary vibe and we've got the same
hair
that's right you know you know what are
you doing with your hair mine is a a
combination
of uh bathroom caulking and helium
what do you have in your um this is uh
a little um like lift powder and just uh
regret and
mild depression
regret is so amazing people don't
understand what it can do for hair
volume
it gives it a real lift you know so
it's funny that you say that that your
co-star and that josh gad
had sort of a radar for knowing who's in
the audience
i mean i'm just curious me aside
what were one of some of your more uh
celeb exciting celebrity
uh spottings while you were doing book
of mormon
well i mean obviously oprah was a big
one
that was a real big one um we all were
very excited to
to have her there um but the weirdest
one for me
was when hillary clinton came with
chelsea clinton
and nana rodham um and that was
very could we could see into the
audience pretty far
so we saw them sitting there and the
fact that we were
that show was so filthy in so many
different
ways that like and i didn't have to do a
lot of that
but um the fact that we were singing
about like frogs and
clitorises in front of nana rodham just
didn't feel right
yeah i would think i don't know about i
usually i'm performing for an audience
that's come to see a tv show
and then occasionally there's been for
some reason
someone famous in the crowd and i
haven't
liked that i don't like that it gets i
get in my head
i think performing for a hillary clinton
or an
oprah um would be difficult like you'd
wanna you'd keep stopping and thinking
that's
oprah and here i am i gotta stay in
character do you know what i mean
yeah i didn't really have um i'm not
saying that i'm
i'm not professional because i am
professional but i would look directly
into the audience sometimes and be like
there they are there's the person um
because i would have a few moments that
i knew i could get away with it
but it was not like i remember when like
james franco was there and james franco
was sitting in the audience and i was
just staring at james franco
to to the degree in which he winked at
me
and then i winked back
i i was there the night james franco was
there and i was staring at james franco
he's staring at you and i winked at
james franco
and he winked at me and then at you so
it was like we all just passed it around
that seems right i i'm sorry that's
exactly what happened
it's okay um it's okay it was a long
time ago
you